[Music]
he's Bob Costas Bob did not retire
yesterday by the way the only reason why
I wanted to have Bob on he's stepping
down with his Olympic duties and maybe a
little bit with football night in
America Bob did you add more work to my
plate that's all I want to know to your
plate yeah I don't think so because
you're not involved in Thursday Night
Football and there will still be Sunday
Night Football so I think you're good
good all right well thanks for looking
for work put in a word for you and and
just so people know you're not retiring
no not retiring I just felt that after
doing a dozen Olympics at this point it
just felt like enough I could have
continued but it's always better to step
aside on your own terms and this will
allow me to do a bit more baseball for
the Major League Baseball Network and
maybe if the right situation comes along
not right away but maybe if the right
situation comes along do more the long
form type program I mean that I used to
do sometimes in sports sometimes out
like back in the days of the later show
in late night on NBC or some of the
stuff I used to do on on HBO or on NBC's
news magazines if that opportunity comes
along what are you gonna miss most about
the Olympics it sounds corny but at this
point having done a dozen of them what
I'll miss the most is the colleagues and
the people I work with many of whom I
grew up with in the business many of
whom have been friends of mine for 30
years or more and being the person who
at least in prime time
carries the ball for the people who
worked so hard not just those and you've
been around then enough to see people
working these 18 or 20 hour days but
it's all the months and years leading up
to it a lot of them probably in the
world to collect the features and the
information in the background on
athletes from more than 200 countries if
we're talking about the Summer Olympics
being at the center of that and
surrounded by so many people who are so
dedicated to the task I think that's the
part that I'll miss the most when did
you know that you kind of settled in and
this is what you wanted to do or meant
to do when you
because you as I said yesterday it's not
easy what you do and but but to be able
to make it look easier than what it
should be did you get to a point where
you said okay I've kind of settled in I
figured this out I don't know that you
ever figured out a hundred percent
because it's impossible to do perfectly
it's such a vast undertaking and there's
so many different expectations and
perspectives but after the Barcelona
Olympics at 92 which was my second one I
my first one at the prime time host and
it was pretty well received I began to
feel more comfortable with it it's
interesting though because I don't know
about you but as much as I admired Jim
Mackay and I truly admired him and I was
lucky to call him a friend during the
last 15 years or so of his life as much
as I admired him
I never thought hosting the Olympics was
my professional goal I thought calling
baseball games for basketball games or
something like that and one thing just
kind of led to another and the next
thing you know a dozen Olympics you got
to a point though where you were
comfortable enough or the network
allowed you that freedom to have an
opinion was that ever discussed or was
that just just a natural progression
that I feel it I see it I say it it was
sometimes discussed because there was
always a tightrope to walk relationships
with the IOC relationships with the home
country especially if that country was
an authoritarian nation I mean I
understood the the differing priorities
if you were running NBC Sports a
gigantic investment is involved here
billions of dollars when you consider
the rights fees and the production costs
and everything else and while they were
willing to let me speak my mind or ask
pointed questions in an interview maybe
more than someone else would be inclined
to do there was sometimes a point that
they didn't want me to go beyond and
then there'd be a behind-the-scenes
negotiations a little bit of pushback
and you kind of settled somewhere in the
middle sometimes what do you think about
Los Angeles getting the Olympics
and uh if the travel ban with a
president Trump how that is going to
impact this vote since they're gonna be
voting on it now but then you're gonna
have yeah you know we it's not you know
for what twenty twenty four people think
it's far down the road and it is seven
years down the road but the vote the
decision just around the corner and we
can only guess there's so many different
constituencies within the IOC we can
only guess how some of them will feel
about American policies and and
president Trump's initiatives and what
effect that might have on Los Angeles's
chances I'll say this from where I said
Los Angeles is probably the city best
situated to pull it off because it has
so many usable venues spread all around
LA and now add to that no matter what
you think a Stan Kroenke leaving st.
Louis and building his new sports Mecca
in in the Los Angeles area that adds
more facilities so I think they're
better situated to pull it off than the
other cities that are bidding for it but
there's always politics involved yeah I
was told that they might swap it and
have Paris go before Los Angeles because
of the travel ban and and voting on it
have you heard anything and what do you
think about that possibility well and
again I don't want to speak out of my
depth here but Paris has issues of its
own one issue is not the setting itself
spectacular to have an Olympics in Paris
and have the Eiffel Tower and the
schoenflies a and the Louvre and all the
rest as some of the backdrops but they
have had their own problems with
terrorism and indigenous terrorists
there may be more of them per capita in
some European cities and there are in
the United States and security is an
ever-growing concern so that's going to
be among among the things the questions
I guess that those who represent Paris
will have to answer for the IOC so I
really it's a jumble to me and I guess
there's pluses and minuses on either
side of it your advice for Mike Tirico
have you given him or
will you give him any advice taking over
the Olympic throne you know we've spent
a good deal of time together especially
lately and of course the first bit of
advice is the same bit of advice that
every one of us got when we started in
the business no matter what we wanted to
do just be yourself
and of course you can't just be yourself
until you pretty much mastered robotic
li the basics of the business and that's
when a personal style and a personal
touch begins to emerge just be yourself
is the easiest device to give and one of
the hardest things to do and it only
comes when you become comfortable and
confident enough to let your own
personality come out but I think the one
bit of solid advice that I've been able
to give them is it's important to know
what you don't need to know and after a
couple of Olympics it dawned on me you
know what no matter how hard you study
no matter how dedicated you are there's
no way you can know every platform diver
from Bolivia or every cross-country
skier from Finland and why should you
try the role of the host and Jim McKay
was the guy who pretty much set the
template for it the role of the host is
to be a good generalist to really know
the history of the Olympics to really
have some perspective on it
to know a lot about the host city and
the host nation and to know a lot about
the two dozen or so stories and athletes
that are likely to be the focus in
primetime and then something comes onto
the radar screen unexpectedly the
researchers are terrific and you have to
be able to take a briefing quickly and
make a narrative out of it even if you
didn't expect that to be part of the
story but if you spend all your days and
nights for months leading up to the
Olympics trying to memorize every
hurdler from Peru that really is a waste
of your time and energy so that aside so
I've been studying the the losers from
Kazakhstan so I should not be doing that
right now for the Seoul Olympics is what
your self no that's the one exception
because losers from Kazakhstan Oh Casa
nating two people in Omaha so I stay on
that I'll let you go with
with baseball in the lower levels the
minor leagues thinking about putting a
runner on second base to start extra
innings your your thought about baseball
trying to speed up play tinkering a
little bit with this idea
I'm good with speeding up play but once
a game goes to extra innings you want it
decided the way a baseball game is
decided the sport that really needs to
think so much about pace of play but
about how they decide games that go to
overtime or the equivalent of extra
innings is football yeah and the fact
that you get an exciting ending should
not obscure how utterly ridiculous the
NFL's overtime rules are and this is not
an anti Patriot thing the Patriots had a
great comeback and over the course of
nearly two decades now they've been just
a remarkable story one of the great
franchises in the history of sports and
what Brady did is off the chart but
suppose the flip had gone the other way
and suppose arguably the greatest
quarterback in NFL history after the
greatest comeback in Super Bowl history
never touch the ball in overtime that's
what happened to Matt Ryan the other
night it happened twice in the playoffs
the previous two years to Aaron Rodgers
one of the best quarterbacks ever and
the rough equivalent of that would be if
it's a world series in the seventh game
of the world series since every playoff
game in football is the equivalent of a
seventh game in another sports seventh
game of the world series you're in extra
innings at the visiting team scores in
the top of the inning on a home run game
over but if they score on a scratch
single or a sacrifice fly then the home
team gets to bat in the bottom of the
inning it's absurd on its face and I
knew that eventually I don't know how
they dodged the bullet this long but
eventually it was going to come back to
bite them in a Super Bowl and it did
it's just a dumb way to conclude a great
game well this is a way to conclude this
interview as well Bob I thank you for
all the advice with the Olympics and
you'll be missed but I'm sure you'll be
you
around I'll be around thanks Dan Thank
You bud that's uh Bob costis Major
League Baseball Network and still
contributing to NBC the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]